and thank you very much and people will
be going to the polls in just a few days
time policy of course is going to matter
because until matter as well so why
should people trust you because I think
if you look at what I do as a politician
what I say I'm gonna do and what I do I
have a record I think of delivering for
people where it really matters and
whether that's when I was running London
when I was able to cut crime very
substantially or deliver more affordable
homes and people thought we ever could
or cut delays on the tube by 30% yeah
you know deliver a pretty successful
Olympic Games I don't never look at what
since I stood on the steps of Downing
Street four months ago I said I'd do
120,000 more police they're being
recruited now I said we build 40 new
hospitals actually the money is going in
not just for six but for 34 others as a
result the decisions we're not worth
taking just the ceiling yes but that's
essential there will be 14 new hospitals
built as a result of the decisions we're
taking at plus 20 upgrades we're now at
fifty thousand more nurses we are
investing massive were in another
classroom you and I are always in
classrooms when we do these interviews
were putting money into every primary
every secondary school in the country
that's happening now we want to get on
and deliver and the biggest thing that
we've got to get right is brexit that's
the thing that's been hanging over us
the last three and a half years and we
have a plan to do it we have a deal
that's ready to go and yes it was very
frustrating people say how can we you
know believe you because you couldn't
come out in October and well it was very
frustrating Parliament passed a special
law that made it impossible for us to
come out in October you remember Labor
lib dems SNP got together to force a big
part of your pitch only we can get out
but can people January 31st when it
comes to brexit because last month
you told businesses in Northern Ireland
that they would face no forms no checks
no berries of any kind under your
breakfast and you also went on to say
that if anyone asked them to fill out
the form they should phone you up
personally and you'll direct them to
throw that form in the bin or how can
they
this government document that was leaked
this week says that that's not true that
there will be checks and forms yes I am
and look at what we say in our manifesto
look what we're going to do deliver that
the deal that we've done with no
absolutely not the deal we talk with the
EU is a brilliant deal and it allows us
to do all the things that brexit it was
a bat so it's about taking back control
of our borders money laws but unlike the
previous arrangements it allows the
whole of the UK to come out of the EU
including Northern Ireland and the only
checks that there would be would be if
something was coming from GB via
Northern Ireland and was going on to the
Republic then there might be checks at
the border into Northern Ireland and
that's wrong so you're saying this is
wrong the government's own impact
assessment is wrong your brexit
Secretary is wrong all these people are
wrong right yes because because there's
no question of their being checks on
goods going ni g b or g BN is their part
of if you look at what the deal is were
part of the same customs territory and
it's very clear that there shall be
unfettered access between northern
ireland and the rest of gb and the and
the only reason this is this is another
of these things that has been produced
by the Labour Party when your own brexit
secretary is saying that there's gonna
be checks when this document says ugly
checks when your own impact assessment
says that will be checks people will be
wondering if actually the whole of the
of the UK comes out of the EU where they
where a UK government why would we put
checks on codes going from mi to GB or
GB to NI it doesn't make sense so so the
issue is what how to avoid a hard border
in Northern Ireland and we can do that
by making sure that there are by having
some checks on goods that might be
proceeding into the Republic that this
is a breach and what this deal allows us
to
is come out on January 30 and it is in
sharp distinct labels they have no deal
at all it's been the whole of next year
control over the immigration system
you've talked about wanting to introduce
a australian-based point basis yes
so is that high or lower immigration
levels lower but there's higher
immigration levels in Australia closely
currently in the UK so I misunderstood
your question what we were what we
wanted to do is to use a an Australian
style points based system in I'm not
hostile to immigration as you know so
I'm a believer in allowing people to
come to this country I think you know if
they have talents and they want to to do
things that it in make their lives in
the UK and they can contribute to our
country fantastic and and we benefited
from that
but what we're gonna do is have three
categories as you may have seen from
what we're saying so people who are
exceptional talents they can come in
here people unit first violinists
nuclear physicist prima ballerinas
whatever they're going to come in
startup kings and queens they're going
to come in Sydney a by virtue of what
they can contribute then that there will
be skilled workers and we'll have a
system so that people can come in to
work is my question and then which is
for a sector specific group who won't
have an automatic right to stay but will
come to do particular jobs and stay for
a while and that's that that's a third
cast my question is if you want to see
lower emigration yes why are you
adopting a system based on the
Australian model which has higher
immigration currently in the UK modern
sumption a member the committee put
together by the actual government to
look into what's happening in Australia
says it's generally seen as a liberal
model that would increase migration
rather than decrease it well it depends
how you apply it
Sophie and what we're going to do is the
migration Advisory Committee will tell
the government what's happening and we
will take a view about how to
control it so that the Margaret to tacit
okay well I've said that what we want to
do is bear down on migration
particularly of unskilled workers who
have no job to come to and I think
that's what's happened over the last
couple of decades or more you've seen
quite a large number of people coming in
from the the whole of the EU Oh 580
million
you know population able to treat the UK
as though it's basically part of their
own country and the problem with that is
there's been no control at all and I
don't think that that is democratically
accountable you've got to have a system
that by which politicians can say the
people well yes we are letting people in
but we're doing it in a way that is
controlled make sure you guarantee that
numbers will come down yes I can I can
make sure that the numbers will come
down because we'll be able to control
the system in that way and what I don't
think is right is to have a an
uncontrolled an unlimited approach to
that that's what Jeremy Corbyn and the
Labour Party are offering they're saying
they're going to have complete free
movement and I think you know that is
absolutely not what people may not be up
for negotiation
well actually they've said they're gonna
keep free movement if you read what
they're saying and I think that's wrong
I think that people want to see
democratic control I think I don't think
people in this country a hostile at
immigration at all they're lending
hostile interests but they want it
democratically controlled and that's
what breaks it allows us to do that's
why we need to get this thing through
which we can before Christmas and then
comment on January the 31st and the ifs
the Institute for Fiscal Studies says
that as a blueprint for five years in
government the lack of significant
policy policy action is remarkable so
what is the single most radical policy
in your manifesto well I disagree with
that very strongly look at what we're
going to do with first of all brexit is
the most radical profound change that
Brenden that happen use it well I do
because that's right well there's a
there's a 100 billion pound
infrastructure revolution that we're
going to introduce we are going forward
with all sorts of programs going to
build a million more homes we're going
to put 20,000 more police on the streets
of our country we're going to get rid of
automatic early release for serious
sexual violent offenders with a reformed
our prison system the 2.5 billion pound
investment in prisons we are we are we
are going to look at the transport
agenda we're going to drive this
performative of this country because
many people would look at Labour's
manifesto like or not it's a radical
manifesto at the concept of manifesto
some people would say it's merely fixing
the issues that the last nine years of a
Conservative government so you're
talking about police officers 2010 since
2010 23,000 police officers have been
cut you're now going to introduce rehire
20,000 you've scrapped the nursing
bursary now you're going to rehire rate
you're talking about getting brexit done
at the same time that many people will
see this is a little bit more money and
you're just going to redo some massive
program of investment in public services
from healthcare to education policing
crime plus infrastructure which will
transform this country what we want to
do as a one nation Conservative
government is your night and level up
across Korea that's why we're investing
in every Prime in every secondary school
in the country because I want every
child in the country to be able to make
the most of their talents this is if we
get the chance with a majority
government on Thursday to implement that
manifesto it will be transformative of
our country and it just and it's not
just brexit brexit is indispensible you
can't move forwards without brexit but
this manifesto will
with if you look at what we're doing
with roads rail telecommunications of 5g
telephony with gigabit broadband this
will bring just there's been a lot of
criticism saying you can't completely
trust all of the figures all of the
promises in the manifesto one thing in
your manifesto is a promise to deliver
50,000 yes yes 31,000 is because even
accuracy important I mean I explained
this many times so far it's very
important problem we have in the NHS
that there are 19,000 nurses who would
leave the system unless we put the
investment in now and that's what we're
going to do and let's be clear not exact
we were already working in the NHS and
you nurses know they're not Leo you're
right that's but you're right there what
we're saying is that we'd be down 19,000
if we hadn't put this investment in
we're gonna have 31,000 new as a result
the investments were making in that
50,000 more nurses we're also gonna have
as I say 40 new hospitals in two schemes
that have no merit we're talking about
tens of millions of pounds to start
architects drawings to start business
cases to start planning a permission to
get these things going that's what you
need to do and that's what we are doing
this is a very dynamic and very
ambitious government we're very
ambitious for this country and but on
you know people go on and on about trust
I think the trust has been undermined in
this country and Trust in politics has
been undermined but it's been undermined
by people who for three and a half years
as you said yourself promised to deliver
brexit and then didn't in Parliament has
held brexit up
that's why we have to have this election
we have to have this election to fix
this broken Parliament and move forward
we think if we get brexit done and we
can deliver the agenda that set out in
that manifesto I believe will be
absolutely transformational for this
country and that's what we want to do
and that's the choice on Thursday you
look at our to our to manifest as you've
invited the comparison actually ours is
is ambitious very very powerful it will
drive the concrete forward and afraid
Labor's would be economically ruinous
and that is every independent assessment
says if you if you raise borrowing by
1.2 trillion Park you put out you put up
but about quantum differences and you
your labour would labor normally ends
their government with an economic crisis
these guys were starting work now by
putting up for a bite to 1.2 trillion by
putting out taxation on individual
taxpayers by 2,400 pounds their plans
would mean people on as little as twenty
thousand pounds a year were paying a
thousand pounds more in tax
I won't be right we're in the last
weekend now yes the election campaign
have seen the polls narrowing of course
we're fighting for every vote and it's
it's ink I think that this is a critical
moment for this country the choice on
Thursday is unbelievably stark it's
between going forward with a one nation
Conservative government that can get
Rexie and unleash the potential of the
whole country or spending the whole next
year in in complete paralysis with two
referendums one on Scotland one on the
EU with either with the jet when Jeremy
Corbyn cannot even tell us what his
position is on brexit and who is going
to campaign for the deal that he
proposes to do nor can you tell us why
anybody should even vote in an election
that you called if you don't get the
majority will you resign I'm gonna fight
for every vote if you don't mind so if
you what I'm gonna do is concentrate on
the five days before us
but as that is what I think the people
of this country would expect we've got a
we got a we got a very short time to get
our message across it's a message of
hope and optimism about this company
this is the most amazing country on
earth it can be the greatest place to
live
to send your kids to school running a
business that's what we want for this
country the best place to grow old we
can do all that but we can't do it if we
remain in paralysis and with a hung
parliament talking about the election
campaign there's been a lot of energy
expended on trying to look at who's
going to be in what debates when they're
gonna happen who's gonna be doing them
now Sky News has been campaigning for an
independent debate arbitrator Commission
debates some things are true yes in 2018
you actually thought it was a good idea
you said that I certainly support Sky's
campaign to have an independent
commission to make sure we get it right
so if your Prime Minister is that
something that you'll be backing I think
there is it's an interesting idea well I
certainly think and the your basic point
I think is a really good one which is
you know guys like me have got to submit
interrogation in the right to elections
I think the or now 120 third interview
I've done or something like that I'm
very - I've done spend several
interviews on privacy
I've done to prime time one-on-one
leadership debates no Prime Minister has
ever done though anyone has done those
before I've done hour-long phonons I've
done all sorts of things and will
continue to submit to to your
cross-examination and just finally now
the last time we spoke last month I
asked you what the naughtiest thing was
even know and at the time you've said to
me mom make you this promise you said to
me atomic this problem you need to drop
that people I can think of some answer
about the naughtiest thing I've ever
done that's both interesting and what
timely discord damaging I will try and
survive through the next time we meet
okay well here we are
you've got lots of time to think about
it on the know what is the noisiest
thing you have done fine that's not a
thing
I did I did promise to think about it
but I just had been so busy it's like
it's trying to get brexit done
and and trying to find all these thing
I've ever done look I think you'd say if
you I'm gonna have to so I'm gonna have
to come up with her
what was it come on folks help me out
here Kenny what is the naughtiest thing
that you've ever seen me do i I think I
think I you know I I'm a I'm a sometimes
I guess gonna put this I'm a sometimes
when I was riding a bicycle every day
which I used to do I may sometimes have
not always obeyed the law about cycling
on the pavement they sometimes okay I
want you to know how firmly and how
strongly I disapprove of people who
cycle on the pavement and and I and I
think it's wrong I feel bad about it but
I you know I might sometimes have
screwed it up onto the pavement rather
than dismounting before I mean the
naughtiest thing you've ever done is
just like on the pavement very careful
rubric what you said was the naughtiest
thing that I was prepared to admit it's
entirely yes that's right damaging yeah
I don't think but I'd strongly
disapprove of anybody in breaching the
laws of the road and and will indicate
them very thoroughly if we're lucky
enough to be returned with a working
majority on Thursday which is what we
need to get brexit done and move this
country forward pastor thank you thank
you